we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
there you go
hold on a second i'm sorry guys oh he's
got to spray it
get this off yeah we're recording all
right i don't trust your white people
and that's a great intro for this new
episode uh welcome back to we might be
drunk our good buddy
will sylvan thanks for having me man
good to have you shout out to the person
who canceled oh
nobody canceled it's all you thank you
how are y'all doing man mark norman
samuel
doing good what do you seem combative
what's going on
your team on edge no not at all all
right i'll be here
my two favorite whites i'll take it
thank you who was in the running
i canceled yeah
who canceled
all right
well yeah coming here man dude i haven't
seen you forever i i've known you for
how many years oh yeah like
before tupac got shot the first time
that's true
[Laughter]
no no no wow what uh is this always been
the setting or this is a socially
distant setting sadly always we like to
keep a little distance yeah you guys are
ahead of your time you got that right so
was my biological father
very distant socially distant your dad
was jewish
i'm just saying they always take their
black guys always get the bad breath for
being not not being around oh
i i just want to shout to jewish that's
another round all right shout out to you
shout out to the jewish that's what
that's taught me they go on to the
argument that we control the media and
the dialogue for this
uh we're not talking about jewish dads
shout out to the jews that told me i'm
gonna get a bagel never come back
too soon
for that one
that's good
she was about a bad couple years you got
made off you got woody allen you got
epstein you got uh weinstein a couple of
beds
lord landlord
thank god maxwell wasn't jewish we would
have been [ __ ] you know who's just
lane
oh the one that she's got convicted yeah
she got 60 years cdc session
was you're only getting going after me
because epstein is out because he dies
but she would i feel like they would go
after her anyway because she was you
know she was like she was rallying them
up yes she was a recruiter but i do i do
we're gonna be blunt with you we've been
drinking since the last episode with uh
gaff again we've done two two drinking
ups in a day so mark and i will you keep
looking over there that camera's over
there the studio producer the producer
oh oh oh yeah
i'm like you keep looking at the camera
oh i feel better drinking with a guy
with a turtleneck though i feel like i'm
more not more sophisticated after this
we're gonna we're gonna rob uh we're
gonna do an ocean's eleven type heist
sam looks like a drama teacher
who's uh banging his students
[Laughter]
here we go
here's what really happened in macbeth
so yeah so she she said who what's worse
epstein or the person that rallied up
the girls for epstein i guess he banged
him so i guess that's worse but she
recruited she was the scout yeah so
who's
if mark bombs who's responsible him or
his agent oh
good good point time what are the jokes
i mean
i think here's my thing she is uh
she's part of it you can't yeah
and and that's the whole argument right
that she he he commits suicide mm-hmm if
you're not watching this on youtube you
can see what i'm doing my favorite
quotes commit suicide that's that's one
with the sleepy guard that's one where
you're like you see that in a movie
you're like come on yeah i'm not a big
conspiracy theorist guy but that's
that's a layup right there yeah so why
isn't she singing like a canary you
thought oh she's gonna get in trouble so
she's gonna start outing bill clinton
and uh
yeah but i think because epstein had the
names down and she just got the joke
she's got names
i get the celebrities he's like i get
the celebrities you get the girls
aha
but you think she would
say some [ __ ] to get out of the jail
time she's got she's doing a couple
years of yeah but i think she didn't
think she was going to get time because
her main argument was you're only going
out to me because epstein's out the
picture so i think that was their big
push
yeah but that's not enough of a push
because she was still there i mean she
was still involved it's like being like
oh yeah i know they robbed the bank i
was just the wheel man can someone by
the way can someone photoshop a picture
of me rubbing mark's feet like jillaine
did to epstein you've seen that picture
that picture that's gotten around where
she's rubbing his feet man this guy this
guy just sucked wait she's rubbing his
feet yeah
i'm a private jet this guy doesn't live
she was rubbing epstein's feet on the
private jet yeah yeah well he was you
know bankrolling the whole situation she
wanted she wanted that you know rich
lifestyle and jesus
to somebody to a woman oh yeah rub the
feet yeah that's right
she's she was a jewish look at that
she's got the tits out and everything oh
damn she's like uh a chest uh but uh
[ __ ] them can i say that i'm sorry oh
teddy [ __ ] oh teddy [ __ ] yeah of course
but
send it around titty [ __ ] go nuts
feed [ __ ] it does make you mad that we
fly commercial when you see this [ __ ]
though i know you're like we're decent
people pull up the hill
hold up hammer i've seen people do this
on on regular planes well not not they
just put their feet up oh good point
right that's without the titties and the
white girl rubbing it but i see people
do this
we need to conduct an investigation into
these people yes to see how they're
living their lives those people are
worse than epstein yeah anytime someone
takes their shoes off on a flight it's a
balls if you're in like one of those
first class pods and you've got space
that's different that's different put
your penis out if you want yeah out dude
virgin hair but you ain't if you were in
the coach right with all the lab rats
yeah
and you pull out your wait you talk
about take your shirt off i haven't seen
a coach too that's in sandusky
and put your feet under the chair or put
your feet on the
that's crazy i've seen it that's rough
it's gross you're a traveler you're
you're a well-behaved traveler right
yeah i don't know i i always get a
window seat and then as soon as the
doors close lay on the window and knock
out till we land oh you're one of those
guys that's a gift i wish i had that
i'll pass out for 10 minutes but i like
the aisle because i can get up and move
around you're trapped what are you
trying to move around for well you go to
the bathroom you walk around you stretch
out you maybe go up in the overhead you
talk to the pilot you get the wings dude
what the hell are you doing all that on
the damn flight floor i'm bored i'm
bored i need to get up too i like to
stretch especially long if i like to
stretch i pee a lot i could i do coffee
or booze on a flight so i you know i'm
getting up i don't do none of that i
love it crosstalk's crunching before i
go get on the flight get on the flight
and i just knock out you're you're a
health nut well you're like you see like
we we do coffee we drink you're a green
tea guy so i feel like you can kind of
just you take such good care of yourself
that's what i've noticed why is there a
bad stigma too with health it's not a
bad stigma i'm not a human that's a good
boy what's the opposite of a health nut
a gun nut
a drunk a drunk nut
a degenerate
yeah a slob
yeah but but that but a health nut
sounds like bad right well you got nut
in there which is never good yeah you
don't hear about like although it's not
healthy for you though exactly not as
not to call you crazy it's more of like
and then anybody like to bust a nut
that's true if i say i'm a basketball
nut it means i'm crazy because i love
basketball right all right good save
yeah right espn was a um
a 15 year old nut
[Laughter]
he was nuts about teens and he busted a
knife
i assume i heard he had a weird dick
yeah egg-shaped egg-shaped what's that
they called it over each
shaped dick
like omelet no
he wishes
an omelet to compliment that's 10 inches
what is that what is that four eggs
right there jesus i got mushrooms in
here i got bell peppers this is a denver
dick i hope you like feta
uh what's the x-shaped thing i guess the
balls would be hash browns
so wait it looked like it look it's
round like an egg so look i got three
balls is there a way to google this matt
without getting thrown off in uh youtube
egg dick egg dick egg dick
so he's an egg beater
[Laughter]
whoa wait that's black okay that's
will's dick
now i've seen well's dick it's much
bigger that's true we've all seen it
wait wait who said he had an x-shaped
dick they said in the trial one came out
the girls yeah oh two yeah that's how
they identified him
x-shaped dick did they someone said can
we get more details please in the
courtroom it'd be nice we gotta crack
the case did they just say that can we
come can you give us a little bit more
detail
yeah apparently his pickup line was
cockadoodledoo
[Laughter]
yeah man that's uh that's a dark side
every time they saw it they could like
egg shape like go back to the headline
see
there you go
right there when you pull the dick out
girls like excellent eggs
nothing too soon great expectations
exactly
someone asked him if he had an egg
shaped penis
that's what i heard i heard harvey's
dick was all [ __ ] up as well by the
way really so we might have a pattern
here what's that
the freaking um hitler yeah hitler had
one ball micro penis yeah the michael is
that right yeah that one ball oh i
already had one ball yeah i heard you
have michael pratt never heard about the
one ball thing pull it up i think i
think i believe that's true i definitely
know the micro penis i've seen enough
history dude i'll tell you the history
channel leans on hitler the way cnn
leans on trump
they hate him on twitter but they also
kind of love him let's be real which one
who's this they keep the life history
channel loves oh yeah they always like
and this is
hitler in the fifth grade
he could have been an artist this is
hitler when he was when he took up a
hobby in in high school right really did
have one testicle yeah from the guardian
whoa
you think that's why i did it
yeah i think you got it uh dez bishop
got one testicle does it yeah he talked
about all day well he hates jews
what about this micro peanut i've never
heard about the micro what's the michael
penis
it sounds like what do you think it is
what do you think of it combine the two
words i mean michael
what's a microchip pull them up there it
is that's not even a p like
that's a pain that's a belly button
hold on hold on we need a better photo
are we going to get in trouble for this
man is that a microphone oh you're going
to blur this right yeah i'm blurring
this holy hell that's whoa that is that
but that's not even a micropenis that's
like an any penis that's an innie
uncircumcised any remember when you were
a kid and they were like belly button in
your audi
the poor kid doing that with his dick
yeah that's gotta suck
by the way shout out to all the women
when they when they had sex with these
dudes and they still moaning like uh-huh
uh i think the women are penetrating
them i don't think they're doing
anything i'm saying that that's not
going inside to them to they still like
being there for the dude like deserve a
battle they deserve like you know
they're keeping the world safe i feel
like a woman's being nice my girl every
time i go down on her i feel like she's
being nice i don't know what i'm doing
down there really i think you know what
you're doing it's pretty
self-explanatory still i think people
like to act like the vagina is so
complicated i don't know i think you get
the hang of it i think you definitely do
you figure you figure it out yeah and
then she'll guide you and stuff when i
was in high school my high school
girlfriend were pretty hot and heavy and
i one day i just said hey look
i'm gonna go down on you and i want a
full report i want you to say what i'm
doing wrong what i need to do more of
what sucks what to get rid of and and it
hurt but i learned a lot you was that
proactive back then oh yeah that's how
mark passed high school english
yes it was my third grade teacher
did she did she really did you really
ask for like and she gave you pointers
totally totally and it's still i still
use them to this day well it's actually
very smart because mark is is trying to
succeed and you succeed by failing and
then asking for notes exactly
good at anything that's a good point
yeah i learned a lot that's a great
that's a great way to live mark it's
stung don't get me wrong what's sung
about it well she had
thank god we went with different ones
too that's pretty good what did you say
i said chlamydia
oh [ __ ] you guys are having sex with the
same girl
i want our periods of thinking
our jokes are synced up we've been
hanging out too much i don't know dude
every time you're i i hope i don't get
cancelled or kicked out your hair looked
like you got a yarmulke on it it was a
shadow oh i could see it this dark in
the background yeah is it is it um your
birthday or something or my birthday
hanukkah i don't know where i told you
guys where yamica's right on your
birthday
why am i going gray is that what it is
no you just said thank you sir right i
see well you got a little gray i got
grounded no no in the background but on
the back it's black as nice
yeah do you want to put the
dye in the back oh no i don't touch it i
mean you know chicks like the gray do
they yeah it's a good movie is that what
they
they tell you i think a lot of girls say
it's distinguished they say it's refined
you're a little older a little salt and
pep little uh what what's the word uh
the girls we hang out with yes silver
fox we're going for it what does
epstein's girl say
they didn't like the gray
they like a frosted too they like the
eggs
is there any bacon with this you know
you know i'm jewish i'm gonna eat bacon
wait you guys don't eat bacon right i
eat bacon
i think that's that's that's yeah it's
orthodox shoes
you know
religious jews don't touch it is that
what kosher what goes great kosher he
works every saturday he's not full he's
worked with me on saturdays we've done
the road together buddy whoa
aziz tour we have a disease together and
uh will is i have to say i love will was
like one of my good friends will is the
ultimate troll will [ __ ] with you
nonstop he i remember will and i once we
stayed in a dumpy hotel i don't know
what we were thinking about really on
the aziz tour you couldn't hook it up
well we we choose our hotel we got
buyouts and we choose our own hotel and
we and we thought it was nicer than it
was i text well where you stand i'm like
i'll just stay with will
we start walking years ago we start
walking down the street and we walk a
while to see and i'm teasing will
because he got so much luggage with him
it's all so much luggage i got one
blockage out you had stuff with you and
i'm and i'm telling will like let's
let's [ __ ]
take an uber to meet him because that's
like a long walk down this weird highway
and well's like now let's walk it's like
[ __ ] it i'm like damn well you want to
go everywhere gorilla style we're in the
car will goes why you calling me a
gorilla
what the [ __ ] the driver is like jesus
guys you can tell what the hell your
worst one was uh phil hanley oh hanley
stayed at a hotel um um uh ricky velez
axe phil you know just get the hotel and
now you know i get my credit card and
stuff right phil hannah booked a hotel
with a sharing bathroom what with the
yeah well it's very unlike phil phil
yeah i love phil phil is a prissy [ __ ]
phil likes to save money more than he is
really yeah wow
well he's saving up for
that's nine cardigans
you know phil phil will stay in a
[ __ ] uh homeless shelter but he shows
up with a [ __ ] new silver rolex yeah
was it worth it
was it worth it he's canadian what do
you say these hotels he able to buy
wallets phil's gonna have to fill on
here to promote his new special coming
out which i i can't wait that'll be soon
that's right looking forward to went to
the taping he killed him he killed it he
was great oh yeah we're talking right
now with uh again oh yeah are you
[ __ ] with phil on the road right now
he [ __ ] with me more than [ __ ]
really
that's not what i hear tell me how is he
[ __ ] with you you don't fail with his
um
quick zing yeah
he's funny though phil shits on you like
like a brit where like you don't know he
insulted you until as you're like
walking it's like a wedding drive-by
it's like that samurai guy cuts you so
quick and you know you're cut right then
later you're like [ __ ] my arm came off
oh your next your head starts sliding
off
ah you missed
that's perfect what cities have you been
in well uh we was uh we just did
charlotte we did uh charleston you guys
haven't been doing this i love
charleston i did charleston not
charleston what did i say you said
charles charleston charles
they changed it yeah same name
been around for a while
how was where did you play in charleston
um shoot i forgot the theater
oh what's up
oh i think i played that i played that
with louie beautiful theater by the way
that's a beautiful city that town i
never seen the whitest of white people
oh it's like yourself you guys will be
poor the weekend over there
i'm not lying i'm not like they're very
white yes southern charm is a lifestyle
over there there yeah for sure that's uh
charleston's a a beautiful
uh city oh yeah yeah great houses great
food yeah
it's almost like new orleans if it got
its [ __ ] together you know
new orleans like party and booze and
charleston's like we'll sit on the porch
in a suit and drink yeah i went by the
water too in charleston yeah do you do
that on the road or you are you don't do
none of that stuff what do you what are
you doing
and
make some calls and that's about it but
i want to i want to walk around because
the city is really nice but you know so
by you know put a double mass were you
flying private no damn commercial
yeah
really
what uh
plane land that's all that matters what
about the dave chappelle tour weren't
that that was not tour but you guys were
going to the um what do you call the
compound oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that was
probably that's probably yeah how was
that that was nice chappelle oh man that
was one of the best things of 2020 like
like 2020 i was so depressed but i
didn't then i went to hang out with
chappelle in ohio man you toured with
everybody that was freaking so fun man
it looked like summer camp over there
but you know when you tour with these
people like it's so much fun yeah ways
whether it's chappelle aziz louie right
um who else i found you used to tour
with cal williams cat oh yeah
you got to tell some cat williams
stories all right
he's got the best cat williams stories i
love cat cat williams who's taller you
were kid i'm controlling the kids all
right because you're what five two but
yeah but cats uh career is way taller
than that
that me and my career are stacked on top
well what there was a story with you and
kat where
you guys took the private jet and he
drove right oh yeah yeah tell that story
no no i want to say that that state i'll
tell you this other story though tell us
something about it it's a cat was on
stage he comes out on stage right and
cat
cat will let you take pictures but in
the beginning so he comes out he tell
the car go ahead take your pictures take
your pictures
go ahead [ __ ] go ahead
all right all right all right you get
enough all right hey my camera's off
[ __ ] all right and he starts telling
his jokes he's talking about telling the
jokes and this is an arena this is a
yeah this is a this is a theater in um
seattle i believe okay and then and cat
is walking around doing his jokes
and as some dude was like [ __ ] that i
want to repeat
he got his camera out now he got his
camera out but the light
do we
like like the stage is lit like [ __ ]
we got like reset lights yeah right and
cat is just doing his jokes and then
can't just look like
[ __ ]
and he he walks off stage in the
audience and go what i told you and then
bash them in the head with the
microphone
wow and then the guy was like
and the cat walked back on stage anyway
like i was saying wow i went right back
into his routine yeah i mean that must
have killed just that noise dude it's
online it's on youtube oh yeah yeah you
could say it's falling up
it's funny as [ __ ] wow what about the
bag of money you told me about that
okay so cat cat is very generous right
yes i mean the first time i met kate i
did a show in l.a at a comedy club and i
i i would what was the club yet uh the
laugh factory good club i liked it yeah
good one i just went up they just put
game they gave me a guest spot and i did
a good job right and then cat went up
behind me and cat goes damn i was just
gonna work out some jokes but this [ __ ]
make me want to work yeah so yeah that's
nice
and he didn't know you before this oh he
knew me but we didn't like he knew me
like we we worked at caroline's in some
other clubs but this is the first time
we interacted you know so at the end of
the show cat comes up and he said come
here i want to talk to you my heart
starts racing i'm like what the heck you
know you know you know you know the
history you know about cat cats gangsta
yeah oh yeah so i want to talk to you i
go what he says these clubs
they they they shoot us like [ __ ] and he
just goes in his pocket i'm like oh
he pulls out a lot of money and put in
my hand
you deserve this for all the work you
did young man
and i go
thanks can't put but you don't have to
shut up take it
you put the gun in your head
put the money in your pocket yo he's the
opposite a mugging dude he just gave me
this money how much did he give you it
was 800 it was 800
100 bills and this is in the 80s
[Laughter]
yo he just gave me this money i felt
like i didn't know like i thanked him
like a thousand times like wow
this is the nicest dude right oh two
weeks later at the comedy store same
thing happened again they gave me a
guest bite and cat goes on after me and
then and i'm outside hanging out he said
come here
i can't believe it god damn it you gonna
make me lose my money and he just goes
in his pocket my cat kelly's cool shut
up and he just gave me everything he had
in his pocket he's like a pimp dude he's
no he's a freaking he's an amazing human
being and he's gave me this money
and just because you know he feels like
as hard as we were yeah
and they don't pay a [ __ ] they didn't
pay me [ __ ] two weeks later will was on
the street corner working for him
actually a week later he hit me up too
whoa
that's a great technique he's like yo
really yeah and i was like yes
how is how was the road with him
uh great kratt
treats me nice he utmost respect and
he does he does i never seen anybody do
this
every time he goes in his writer he gets
the the local paper
the local paper of that town not the not
the nation
with the local local paper that's right
he reads it from beginning to end when
he comes out he does 15 to 20 minutes on
that town wow crowd is going [ __ ] crazy
that's hard to follow it's like having
an opening act right yes that's that's
doing local right
this guy can't go nowhere cat is doing
that for himself wow
he cares yeah that's rare and the cat
does a show within the show and he'll
he'll put on like five comics right the
host
five other comics right intermission and
then cat right so they get a show like
uh like the comics on the show is like
like uh he had uh uh
ginny yashway uh-huh um um john
witherspoon
so like he puts a show within the show
and then so he's like yeah i gave you
[ __ ] a show so now i could do what the
[ __ ] i want to do
and and and what the [ __ ] you want to do
is still freaking amazing of course he's
hilarious but he's working on stuff
always yeah he's kind of yeah cat is
constantly working now this could be a a
black thing and correct me if i'm wrong
yes
you're making me want to work edward
[Laughter]
he
made it off of a spot on a movie he did
a movie what was it friday after next
yeah was that what broke him i feel like
that's the thing in the black community
where you can be in a movie and kill it
like chris tucker although he did def
jam well
chris tucker killed so many movies this
is it yeah he's just awesome people will
be like this guy's funny we'll go see
him where is it a white guy if you're in
a movie and being funny if you're like
that's a funny guy in a movie i'll say
this
cat
mate cat is who made cat that makes
sense his stand-up
always was solid so he was doing
stand-up the whole time yeah the whole
time okay and then he did this little
movie spot which gave him more like
people like oh
so then when they went to go see him it
was like he was already like
it's almost like someone who came out
and blow up on something but they only
got ten minutes to start ten minutes to
stand up or they're not really that
funny at all yes so you're saying so
that makes it it's like when you finally
get that light and then like okay let's
see what you got and then oh yeah you
just got a bump that was all it was
right he got a bump he got a little bump
but i think yeah but cat but no he's
been funny how about how about the time
and was it
in new york where he was throwing the
money out can we tell that story oh yeah
yeah okay so yes this is what i was
looking for was this in new york this
was
this is one on one of these tour dates
so cat comes out right
at so after the show so what he like i
say he does a show within the show right
and then cat comes out at the
intermission brow is going [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ]
crazy right
and then um the music is playing he's
just pacing the stage of the crowd going
crazy ah
oh my god cat and then he just take off
his he got a diamond a diamond ring he
takes it off
and he throws it in the crowd he just
goes like someone catches it right and
he's pacing he takes off his rolex some
expensive ass watch
right
with diamonds around him and then throws
it phil hanley jumped up and grabbed him
he has a
a fur mink hat what he takes off the
mink hat and throws in the audience wow
he got a thick fur mint coat
takes off the main coat
and throws it crowd is going crazy
meanwhile he has not started yet
he's pasting right we wouldn't be able
to follow his nonverbal act no god no i
throw my apple watch really what are you
doing
cassio
cassio timex timex so so he throws he
throws his so then he goes like he's
trusting his pockets he goes one hold on
one like one minute he goes backstage
now i i should have preference um cat
gets his money in cash wow all cash [ __ ]
around uh and they put his cash in two
paper bags geez
crap at the time he was getting paid 250
000
per show okay right
um and
i they put two paper bags right i think
he had either four paper bags or two
paper bags with all the money right and
uh when when we're on the tour bus he
gets up to 12 bucks and he takes his
money with him because he don't trust
the bus drivers
he leaves it backstage behind the
curtain right okay um and he's pacing
the stage facing the stage he's checking
his pocket he'd go i'll be right back he
goes back and grab one of the papers oh
my god right comes out how's he gonna
follow us with the material hey uber's
weird huh
i mean
he can't beat cash hold up hold up
hammer he takes the bag
throws an audience it didn't fly out one
person caught them what right that's
probably a hundred grand
whatever it was one person caught the
bag right
backstage his security and he's like the
beginning of fargo it's security his
manager going crazy yo
cat just threw one of the bags in the
audience captain the store on the backs
of audience he's picking the stage right
crowd going crazy and the person who
caught the bags disappointed
it's just a paper
he got a rolex i got a bag
right and can't go i'll be right back
and they say oh they said on the walkie
talkie he's coming back for the other
back
hide it god hide it because you're like
we don't want this dude to blow all the
money he's making tonight yeah and that
guy's probably getting paid off that bag
the security guy so they hide the bag
right and he comes backstage she goes to
the to the secure and the people weighs
the bag weighs the bag
and he goes and then we'll know cat and
then he goes back on stage this is like
the movie heat but he's robbing himself
yeah he grabs him he grabs the mic he
kills the music he gets i have more
gifts for you but the [ __ ] in the back
are [ __ ] up
anyway
welcome
wow
jesus he's the best i love him i love
him off these stories alone i didn't
have any of those stories with tom papa
i'll tell you that
he thought his volga in the audience
what about
can you tell the the jet story or now i
won't say everything man i feel like i
feel like yeah save it he flew upstairs
he is an egg shaped penis yeah anyway no
cat william sounds like the best oh he's
one of the best man and obviously one of
the funniest as well so yeah shout out
hey man cat williams if you're ever
listening yes we'd love to have you oh
what do we call this the drunk tank what
do we call in this room yeah i like that
and cat i'll say also man he paid me the
most ever out of all the comics i worked
and you've worked with the biggest i
work with a lot of com but don't don't
get by not
criticizing other people
who's your favorite to be on the road
with because you work with everybody
dude there's no i just just to be on the
road with any one of these guys to be
honest man i i have the the i have no
nothing bad to say about anybody i
worked with
with the comments that took me on the
road like all good things what about
cosby
i mean i i wasn't asleep the whole time
[Laughter]
that was just his act now what do you
think
what do you think uh but you're wrong
with chappelle i mean like that's got to
be
amazing i mean dave is such a legend i
mean you know for so long he's been a
legend yeah so i mean i feel like he was
a legend in his like 30s which is yeah
hilarious but and he worked with patrice
i mean will's been around you you were
roommates with patrice in eight years
with patrice you lived with him for
eight years did he
did he uh do you feel like he bestowed a
lot of you know comedy knowledge he was
longer in the game than you oh yeah he
was he was like everyone wake me up
cursed me out and get and drop knowledge
non-stop we talked about so many things
and it's one of those things to be
honest man is is like
you think he's going to be around for a
long time so i'm not taking it in like i
should have like if i would have known
what i know now like i would have like
record like i did i did the first ever
patrice o'neill podcast believe it or
not really big philip 2001
wow i had a mini disc what yeah you my
mini disc yeah and then i patrice was
doing this whole thing about about about
raiding women from 1 to 30
you know 10 10 10 did you know about
that yeah
funny [ __ ] and i said yo dude we should
get some girls in here
and and and do it and talk and do do a
show yeah funny as [ __ ] so we we did we
taped two shows and we got some girls in
the apartment and i cooked some food and
then we what started recording too can
you cook well huh can you cook yeah i
love cooking
when i was eating fish
i would i cook um
huh you're all fish i'm vegan but i'm
not an [ __ ]
so that's no caffeine no booze no no
meat here's no sugar no fish
is that he is so healthy but he's so i'm
not gonna i'm not so healthy but you
know what you treat yourself
occasionally but like whenever you're
eating at the cellar you've always got
some like vegan restaurant food and
you're always like yeah try this try
this you cursed me out
i'd [ __ ] you a little bit literally
you call me the n-word every time i
you know what i know these n-words y'all
and words eat this [ __ ] this is what he
[ __ ] does this is what he does i
brought up the gorilla [ __ ] earlier
this guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] tell us
about opening for kramer
well we'll fluff you off
yeah but
yeah what's your we're like go to v do
you cook vegan i cook yeah i cook vegan
yeah what do you make i make um
uh what do what what do i make
um
like a like a a vegan pasta
okay there you go i do that i made that
sometimes just like the sauce
you do like beyond sausage or something
what do you do i don't i i stopped
messing with with beyond stuff beyond i
heard it
do they put so much [ __ ] in there to
make it taste like meat exactly not it's
like you might you might just eat real
meat eat the meat because there's more
more ingredients in there to
you know [ __ ] yeah that's and they call
it eat it more for the taste and the
nutritional value i mean i actually
think it tastes really good it does
taste good
but you're right if you're talking about
the nutritional value yeah that the
sodium and all the other shouldn't there
be in this step for sure cancer causing
things um
they they put is is just
that's that's the worst way to get
cancer how did you get cancer i was
vegan
i hope it was worth it this other guy's
got throat cancer he smoked a pack a day
and drank every other hour they didn't
say eating vaginas causing cancer i
heard that yeah but if you're gonna get
it going down on catherine zeta jones
it's not the worst way not the worst way
totally yeah you're here yeah you
haven't been [ __ ] for like 25 years
every goddamn worth it i had four
[ __ ] a day
every every time he stopped going down
to go and all that jazz chicago all
right
he uh no catherine zeta jones i mean
come on who's that that's his wife pull
up catherine zeta jones pull up the
scene and entrap me when she goes under
the laser with her ass yeah and see the
white huh you'll see it who's who is she
actress yeah i know
this is why i'm good with names man
she's the one who gave him cancer oh
that's the one that her vagina are they
still married oh yeah yeah that's a good
husband
he said till dad she's like she's like
um
she's though he's the male version of
magic johnson's uh wife oh yes there you
go yeah yeah yeah except magic didn't
get it from his wife
there it is look at that oh come on that
was big in the norman household what
movie is that entrapment
that wasn't that entrapping us that
scene well the problem is she doesn't
have much of an anal but uh
position it really works one more time
matt for the kids at home
we don't wanna
[Music]
that's it
hold up hammer you think that scene
was in the script or they say hey what
skills do you have and she said i could
do this
and they wrote that scene in the
scriptures i don't think holly was
allowed to say that anymore back then
will yeah anybody's guess this is the
90s yeah that's what i'm saying like
look like that scene right there
like let's say she couldn't do that
that's some yoga type movement it might
have been a body double too michael
douglas is hollywood royalty though so i
think it worked out okay for both of
them yeah yeah for sure they look like
night and day look how young she looks
well yeah i mean she look i mean let's
be real he's old as [ __ ] and she's
gorgeous i mean but he's probably
25 years older let's take a guess is
that it 25 sounds all right
i think he could be more than 25. he
might be it might be right he could be
30. now what is the rule here and i've
been drinking i'll tell you i you know
my girlfriend and i the other night were
like who was just going through amazon
25. wow i nailed 25 you nailed it good
job all right thank you but we're going
through which by the way is fine when
he's you know 65 and she's 40.
when he's 80
you know and she's 55. it's a different
ball game right wait wait wait
and she how old is she will she be 55.
wait
wait how old is she now i i assume
they're in that ballpark right is that
is he not 80 now he's got to be pushing
it right that's where the rubber meets
the road yeah when he turns 80 and she's
so that's all fun and games when you go
to distinguish older gentlemen but uh
you know when the diapers come in we
were watching you know taylor and i are
watching uh we're just scrolling through
amazon we're like what can we watch
right now that we're watching that show
yellow jackets for a while on show time
any good it is good all right it's
mindless it's the dialogue is terrible
but the writing is great if that makes
sense the story is kind of oh got it got
it christina ricci is incredible i love
the reach i love her juliet lewis is
hilarious
it's a it's a cool cast yeah uh what's
her name from togetherness the uh man
woman uh
melanie lipski or something she's very
good the cast is excellent you guys are
talking about all these white and white
actors and white movies you know what
there's a black actress on there too
it's for eggman actors i forgot her name
because he's not called mojave is that
is that who it is i don't know but
he coats
52 so he's 77 then okay here's the thing
though 77
so we're scrolling through movies to
watch we get on amazon we get
something's got to give she goes i
remember hating this movie and i was
like i don't think it's that bad it's
nicholson it's keaton it's kind of fun
right we turn it on out of the gate it's
like nicholson is banging amanda pete
and you're like
and and taylor sit next to me she goes i
love jack nicholson but he's not a
handsome older man sure so the fact that
he is banging amanda pete
and he's what 70 in this what does this
and she's 25
what yeah she's a hot younger lady i'm
on the pizza amanda peta is gorgeous
gorgeous and i love jack nicholson but
unless he's playing jack nicholson
that's a man to pete yeah yeah that's
right up your anal will i know your type
she's married to david benioff by the
way who's that game of thrones oh
that guy he wrote uh this book uh [ __ ]
what's the name look up david benioff uh
russian war book it's really uh thieves
obsidian you make a good point cause
when you're watching the movie you want
to feel like it's real city of thieves
the fact that he's banging her
was he was is he rich in the film look
it up look up that's a good question
well you're on a podcast turn your
[ __ ] ringer off yeah but what would
cat william say about this [ __ ] if
you want will's got to do a grubhub like
look at them together it does not look
normal look at that no and i loved it
and i i am a jack nicholson defender to
the death
this is one of the things like you watch
old rom-coms from like the 50s like i
love we're talking about sabrina the
other week yeah humphrey bogart and
audrey hepburn and he's like in his 50s
yeah and she's in her 20s and you're
like this looks [ __ ] hot it looks
weird but that's the same thing
that you that started
when you were watching it blow that up
well he's got to be 40 years older than
her in this city easily because she's
playing under 30 and he's playing pro he
i need to take viagra
you guys are missing the biggest thing
yeah look how good of an actress she is
acting like she's enjoying this but
here's the question this is the dilemma
some women like older men so a lot of
girls get upset like what are they that
hot is the question
the woman that like older men and did
the older men look like jack nicholson
or do they look like who's like a really
hot older guy
uh sean connery
oh he died [ __ ] yeah
richard nicholson bill washington no one
is
denzel is looking great
nicholson
but if he's loaded let's say he's the
ceo of uh
that's a hot order that's a hunk
right now if he dates a 25 year old is
that bad no no she wants to [ __ ] him
that's what my point start [ __ ] this
dude
is realistic if we're talking about
accepting people pete davidson
sorry no well if we're talking about
accepting people we're accepting like
hey you're into this you should be oh
that's a good point all i'm saying is
watching that in a movie and seeing
nicholson look like you can't look like
that and be and like i know you're a
star so it's like if it's jack nicholson
in real life you could [ __ ] anybody
right because we believe it because
you're jack nichols or if he's just a
billionaire
sure yes yes but even bezos is kind of
shredded now have you seen him he's
looking great and i think he's got a new
uh lady on his arm his arms look so good
it's like he's working in those ways
he got that kind of money he could get a
stunt double that's true a body double
yeah
you see it has having like a midlife
crisis he's dressing like a like a weird
guido club guy is that his ex-wife no
yeah no that's not his ex-wife oh his
ex-wife is mackenzie like no yeah
no
there's the ex-wife yeah she's doing
pretty well she's doing crazy well well
he's got a lazy eye and she's giving up
half her money up
why yeah she's for what she's just
giving it away like to charity why is
she cat williams
brown bag in it yeah look bezos is kind
of that's basil he's like 58 he looks
great that's bezos yes
i had a thought where i was like man i
would like i'd love to look that like
that in my 50s and i was like i'd love
to look like that uh today
[Laughter]
good point
[Laughter]
[Music]
he looks hot but he can afford the best
trainer he's got the best food he's got
all right it is easier to be fit when
you've got people just being like be fit
yes
or they constantly
they get the best foods for you that too
because in america they put so much [ __ ]
in the foods even when you're eating
healthy foods there's so much [ __ ] you
got that right no when i gave up chicken
man i gave a trick in 2007 august 2007
never forget i dropped 12 pounds in
about two chickens just they put a lot
of honey i don't want to [ __ ] on you
will but i don't want to use uh you
giving up chicken never forget as a new
yorker that offends me a little bit
911 never forget you giving up chicken
are you trying to save black people good
for you chicken
i'm just saying you giving up chicken is
your 9 11.
either way it was it was burning that
chicken
why do you give up chicken well um
because of the dolphins they put a lot
of [ __ ]
in the chicken is that well yo i went to
i i went to haiti right i went to haiti
one time
and the food i remember i ate so much i
and and i didn't gain a pound
and then and then i was like wow i
didn't get nothing and someone reminded
me like oh haley
no preservatives are just it's in-house
organic all the uh a lot of farm to
table in haiti whereas like some place
like jamaica they get these kfc they
all these other influences by america
they're not sure about america but
they go to these countries and and they
start building and they show these
countries how to make food yeah in
abundance australia is another one where
everything is like i feel like is that
right well it's like all the beef is
just better in australia i feel like
some places
some places well he's been there a lot
you love australia i mean you've
traveled to australia yeah you've
traveled everywhere you've gone but
you've been everywhere
uh adelaide cal gully margaret river
melbourne sydney
damn you're like a you stand out over
there
because i'm black yeah i think you're
exotic in australia
don't you think yeah people look at me
like hey he don't look like an
abolitionist
where's the spear
[Laughter]
damn walk holy [ __ ] oh sorry
um
i will say you go to italy i went to
italy a couple years ago no one's fat
and all they eat is pasta cheese bread
and i'm like what the [ __ ] because their
pastas made different better their food
is made different yeah and also they
stop eating in between we snack like
[ __ ] like yeah
they do have their portion control down
in a different way where like same with
friends like look at the friends like
they just look like of course there's
like if you see like a chef there they
look like [ __ ] because they're just
snacking on that [ __ ] all day but the
people that actually just eat that stuff
yeah they don't look bad yeah i actually
started doing intermittent fasting like
a few years ago
like intermittent fasting oh [ __ ] you
know what that is how many don't eat for
a while
how many hours a day are you allowed to
eat
i okay i'm different i look at it as i
focus on the hours i'm not eating
because that's when your body's using
your body fat
for fuel and energy so when you're not
eating so when you fast your body first
place your body goes to your stomach
there's no food there dennis then goes
and get the fat uh he puts it down and
use that that makes sense yeah so um uh
hunger is not lineal it's it's it goes
up it peaks and it drops so people think
um if you stay hungry you're going your
hunger go and get high and high no it
once you reach your peak and it drops
because then your body just go and
search for the for if you
because all fat is stored energy because
your body's like i can't we don't need
all this right fuel we'll just save it
for later yeah you know later never
comes because because
you eat again in the first place again
your body goes to your stomach for fuel
and so then it never goes to the fat so
um i focus on the not eating
part
how much like it so my i uh you you're
supposed to do 16 hours i average 18 to
20 hours what
everybody calm down wait a minute wait a
minute i'm confused you don't eat for 18
hours if you intermittent fasting is
you're supposed to fast for 16 hours
what and you eat for eight hours when do
you sleep that there's part that's
that's part of it that's part of it so
you let's say you sleep for eight hours
that's another then you just have to do
another eight hours of not eating that
makes sense i do intermittent [ __ ]
where i don't [ __ ] for like a while oh i
do i do intermittent [ __ ] also but i
haven't [ __ ] since 20
20 20. whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait
what yeah i i've been he was asleep the
whole time
what are you going to eat or out though
or does that count against the fasting
yeah
wait that's the whole question so you go
to bed for so you sleep so you sleep for
eight hours then you wake up that means
you have another eight hours of fasting
okay so let's say you wake up at eight
o'clock right eight nine ten eleven
twelve one two three so then you can eat
at three o'clock exactly do you go go
hog wild and eat a bunch of crazy food i
mean you should try not you should try
and eat as healthy but you but i'm
telling you it works yeah and now i i
now i elevate it i'm i'm up i'm doing a
omad you know omad i know nomad
i don't know oh man what the [ __ ] is
that man oh man
i've never heard of obama what is
no
what does that have to do with a
different word that's a good point where
there's no man never has no money you've
never heard of a nomad no no man no
matter someone who travels and has no
home or or place it's just
what doesn't stand
uh
it sounds like a neighborhood in
manhattan doesn't it
i live in norfolk
north madison oh okay well there you go
in manhattan no omad is one meal a day
oh
one meal a day yeah i like oh man and so
i'll leave one meal a day and then but
until it so i shut it down at four
o'clock i eat about 11 a.m and then till
four what and then but i'll eat one meal
and then i'll snack on fruits veggies
now i suck at because i eat a lot of uh
cakes
and stuff okay so you're human you have
a vice but they're vegan cakes right
yeah yeah but but so they said nobody's
still looking huh i'm kidding the vegan
king are they you said something a
racial slur
why did it jump to that it's always
racial i didn't hear it does this thing
just actually repeat yourself i said so
the cakes suck because they're vegan are
they good cakes are you trying to say
they black cakes is that what you're
saying because they saw chocolate cakes
are always lazy
yeah so they they no even though they're
vegan cakes they still your body's still
looking as sugar sure so exactly there's
no sugar in it no there's sugar
vegans go hard on the sugar i don't
think you say your body still looks at
the sugar why well because there's sugar
in it because people think they're vegan
cakes they're healthier but no this
have you seen overweight vegans there's
yes again overweight vegans oh yeah and
like like i remember the first time i
met a overweight vegan like oh yeah i'm
a vegan so i'm like
it's kind of like a it's kind of like a
sex addict to only did you just if you
just
it's kind of like a sex addict only
jacks off a lot is how i look at it a
sex act who only jacks because it's
still not that healthy you're not
actually getting the thing so then i'm a
sex addict
sure no you haven't had sex in two years
yeah but i jack off a lot ah
do you how many times a day you're a
narcissist one i i just want to once a
day once a day is fine yeah that's
healthy i think that's normal you clean
up i used to do three four times a day
three four yeah when was this this was
like i don't know today
you're on tour with cat he was handing
out the money you were doing this
wait wait wait it's three times too much
three is a lot i mean look i'll be
honest we've all been on the road we
were like oh what else am i gonna do
exactly i've been on the road to the
point where you're like okay there's
nothing to do i'm gonna jack off then
you sit there and you wait you're like
guess i'm waiting to like jack off again
yeah
but i'm in [ __ ] royal michigan i do
it for other reasons i was doing it to
save money
you jack off you go to the clubs
all the power all the power's taken away
you don't have to buy drinks for girls
yeah yeah that's good it's like it's
like it's like you wait when um you pull
a wooden gun on magneto magneto yeah
right and he's using his power ah i
wooden gun magneto then try to fire the
wooden gun he's like that's not that
strong though
yeah but still
it's like you know i'm pulling a wooden
gun out or wooden dick out on these
girls like it's wooden dick
doesn't work ladies
unless she's amish
we'll put this credit card in the bar
his forearms this big jesus christ
i was actually i was uh
a bed humper for a while me too
i mean that's what i did then i found
that like oh you can do with your hands
really yeah you were in bed beforehand i
was way but i was waiting i was i mad
hotels for the for the friction but mad
hotel bells around the beds around the
world if you listen to this you're not
tipping your uh housekeeping enough yeah
seriously that's that is a tough job
will's the only guy who's std is bed
bugs
i've never heard of [ __ ] the bed
before
you usually graduate to the bed for real
yeah
the hand is the most basic first step i
mean it's right now no because i my
first time
right sexually or hand no hand okay or
self
manual yes
this would be a great time to jump in
this next ad is brought to you by casper
or by uh tesla
[Laughter]
we might be drunk as sponsored by better
help online therapy we've talked about
better help on this show before and this
month we're discussing some of the
stigmas around mental health first off
you're not a crazy person it doesn't
mean something's wrong with you taking
talking to a therapist is a positive way
to process your life
look we do therapy you got me in it's
necessary it's helpful people go to the
gym people eat right what about your
mind what about your emotions what about
your mental state we all have trauma
we're all [ __ ] up we're all weirdos
gotta get on it
just like going to the gym or the
dentist we should be caring for our
mental health as much as our physical
health
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even online
or live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can start communicating
with your therapist in under 48 hours
give it a try see why over 2 million
people have used betterhelp online
therapy this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and you get 10 off your first
month by going to betterhelp.com
drunk
that's b e t t e r h e
dot com slash drunk and check out
betterhelp's new podcast getting better
wow stories of mental health hear meghan
trainor open up about motherhood or how
nba hall of famer chris bosh tames
anxiety one of my favorites love chris
bosh there you go find getting better on
apple spotify and anywhere else you get
your podcast support the show
and get 10 off your first month of
online therapy betterhelp.com drunk get
on it
uh my first time i i was i used to i
didn't know about
jerky though because back you know
magazines and stuff they never show
people joking no you didn't talk about
it
and so i would i would have these sexual
thoughts and then i would sleep late on
the bed
and then and get erection and then i'll
just you know move my head like oh [ __ ]
yeah and then i i and then i i passed
out i remember i was on my way to sleep
but having thinking about having sex
with this girl by the way when i was
young i had sex
i used to
masturbate to ugly girls right but then
after i finished masturbating i dream
about
hot girls hmm
what do you think is that i don't know
stuff i don't know what it was i just
thought you know she's you know she's
were you attracted to the women that you
were calling in your mind ugly
they were yeah i mean clearly you were
because you were masturbating so maybe
they weren't ugly they were
they they was not as pretty as the hot
girls but that was you know saying
here's what i think about that and this
is my opinion i could be wrong
maybe
they were attractive to you and you were
just going by what society ooh
interesting is calling attractions yeah
maybe the women that you were imagining
to you like they're ugly maybe they're
actually attractive and you're like this
is what society says is okay to be with
or maybe the people who are into feet is
because they they jacked off to socks
when they was young and now they love
feet ain't you i jerked off into socks
yeah are you are you a foot fetish no i
never used to jerk off the socks then
put them on the door and say do not
disturb people will touch the door they
say i will not disturb yeah and the sock
is all hard and stiff
got really awkward around christmas with
the stockings
but yeah interesting what are we talking
ugly when you say a jerk off to an ugly
guy what are we talking here like uh
you kind of look like me without the
beard oh that's pretty bad
okay i get a hot body though a hot body
a hot body i used to also be attracted
i'm still am but
back then i should be only attracted to
big girls how big big real i didn't know
what vagina was
but i knew i wanted it yes and i thought
big girls had more to give like big
girls had bigger titties like she got
they got big they must have
more vagina china yeah it makes sense
right good logic and i i was i was i was
hooking up with a lot of big girls and
then i went i had a skinny girl and i
was like wait a minute this is the same
amount of a job i was getting from the
big guy
same goes for dick a fat guy he's the
same dick
nah when i lost the weight i got more
dick
what yeah how do you get more maybe just
look like more i i can't i think that's
what it is i think mark is nailed it
here
i'm not making up if you lose weight
your dick get bigger we're gonna need a
before and after picture well
that's crazy otherwise every guy would
just get fat because your dick would get
bigger and girls are beating the bad
guys when i lost the weight my dick got
bigger no no we hear yourself no no no
he's saying oh you're right you're right
okay
hmm he thought
why would it get bigger i don't i can't
i know but i think what mark was saying
was it gets bigger by comparison
well weight loss lead to a larger penis
um
yeah it's called it's an optical
illusion
we gotta measure it i never mentioned it
oh there you go i had a girl once told
me um uh i was a virgin child i was 24.
wow
and she told me
she i you know i lied to my dick oh yeah
i'm getting you know you don't do what
i'm do what do i do yeah and she told me
when a girl when girls tell you
your dick is big it's cause your dick is
small cause what they do is
the women like to like like to get guys
with little dicks to gas their heads up
and that's how they get guys with small
dicks to pay for [ __ ] damn cause they
make them feel good oh my god what your
thing is so big like girl we're going
shopping after this
but when when a girl goes up in a
corvette she's like your dick is it's
the biggest dick i've ever seen with a
girl
when the girl tell your dick is small
it's really big cause they don't want to
gas
guys with big dicks heads up got it man
i must have a huge dick
because every woman's been like this is
tiny
i thought i had a small dick for women
walking by in the hallway like this like
thank you
i thought i had a small dick for a long
time
because girls was like oh my god it's
big i'm like here we go again oh
well if you never use a communal shower
you're packing heat buddy a communal
shower yeah you've never been like a gym
where there's like a lot of naked people
that's we don't do that in the hood
yeah we'll just go home take a shower
what about the gym
i'd still go home and take a shower oh
okay
yeah you already i mean there's
athlete's foot and all that [ __ ] yeah
and i hear you no i i i started like now
recently
in my later years
using the local bathrooms to take a
shower but i use flip-flops ah yeah what
about underwear
you gonna wear underwear
in the shower yeah yeah i go in no no
it's a it's a solo shower not oh solo
yeah no no yeah not smart not no prison
showers got it got it well at my high
school we took showers together for real
yeah it was awkward
what happened well you know you were
glad when an asian guy walked in
you dropped the soap no no i went body
wash
nobody's dropping that
but yeah
you dropped the body washer like [ __ ]
i'll buy a new one
exactly what uh
yeah no summer came we used to share
with kids and it was like yeah you know
well you shot with kids right
yeah dude i was 24 i was like let's
[ __ ] let the good times roll i went
to the epstein camp
yeah but wait this is a jewish camp yeah
all right at least you guys are all in
the same uh background
i know i'm just saying i went to school
with uh you know everybody
and it was a
it was a u.n of dicks oh yeah the jewish
camp is all
uh circumcised right
yeah usually there's a few people that
weren't but yeah yeah
did they get bullied
look at you that's a weird it's a weird
bully walking in all right [ __ ] which
one of you didn't see a moil
yeah that's a that's the guy who
circumcises you it's what you do a lot
of oil oh because you you cut it you put
a little you put a little wine in there
sometimes the teeth cut it the what they
use their teeth
they bite it off yeah i heard one guy
use his teeth i heard they kiss it after
is that true and there was no i heard
the story
do they kiss it i heard they suck the
blood and then sometimes the babe will
get herpes because
that's what i said that was that was a
moist give it a good he was giving he
was he would cut it and he'll we'll do
like this i heard that too and then
jesus christ there it is so the worst
way to get herpes imaginable oh my god i
know a toilet seat just moved up a notch
you got it from a [ __ ] moil yeah
moyo sounds like it's a derogatory yeah
boy this guy's a [ __ ] boy oh you're
right it doesn't how many morals moving
into my neighborhood
good morning it really seems to care all
right
how are you getting affected that damn
god damn
yeah now you grew up in brooklyn when
brooklyn was terrifying yeah east new
york east new york east new york is
still bad it's tough yeah i lock my dogs
when i drive around east new york yeah
wow it'll never get gentrified no i wipe
you move in and move right back out a
week later i once i was on a train and a
guy got it was a guy [ __ ] with me on
the train this was many years ago i was
coming back from a gig in in in prince
and i was doing a [ __ ] club called
catcherizing oh yeah
but they let me headline this many years
ago and i remember getting on the train
and i'm [ __ ] like [ __ ] this i'm
drinking a [ __ ] buffalo trace on the
train so i'm pounding a whiskey waiting
to go back it's one of the train yeah
i'm like done with the weekend i'm
taking the new jersey transit home i get
on a train some guy starts [ __ ] with
me on the train what do you look like
weird looking guy described from small
guy white calm down and uh
he's [ __ ] with me
[ __ ] with me so he starts asking he this
is what he asked me he goes he starts he
starts poking people he's just like
asking provocative questions me goes
what do you think about immigration
and i've had like drinks of me so i'm
drunk i'm just like i think they're
taking our damn jobs trying to be funny
i'm like clearly this guy's gonna know
i'm joking
like i don't like i don't feel that way
i'm trying to be funny and the guy goes
you're a [ __ ] bigot and i'm like
you're a crazy guy like i'm not doing it
yeah he starts [ __ ] he starts
fighting he goes i'm going to hurt you
and i'm like oh [ __ ] so he's pre-twitter
i guess when you had to do it in person
so we're walking
we're walking along the tracks i'm
trying to avoid him waiting for the
train he's [ __ ] with me i remember
him texting hanley like oh this dude's
[ __ ] you just needed a hand he won't
come and save you no but i just wanted
to vent i just wanna say hey
2012 okay okay all right and i remember
just being like god damn this guy's
[ __ ] with me and like you know he's
crazy you know like he's got nothing to
lose i'm like just trying to avoid it
yeah i'm hiding on the train i'm trying
to avoid him i finally elude him right
i'm sitting on the on the uh
train ignoring him you're hiding on the
train what's the platform i no i get on
the train finally on the train
a window seat i'm kind of just
i found a way to get away from this guy
he starts [ __ ] with other people he's
not in the right mind right he goes with
another guy what do you think about
immigration and he starts [ __ ] with
the wrong guys
what was it what was it some people's
answers i don't remember but i do
remember this is the part that where it
turned
is a guy
he says to the guy what do you think
about immigration and the guy goes the
[ __ ] did you say to me and he goes what
do you think and the guy's a tough
looking dude and he goes east new york
[ __ ]
and i was like that sounds tough yeah i
can't i can't say chelsea [ __ ]
we got a burgeoning art community what
uh no
but he was he got it [ __ ]
break yourself well he gets in the guy's
[ __ ] face to the point that i'm like
oh this is funny hold on hold on slow
down hammer what did the guy look like
so this is when it got creepy the guy
who was talking [ __ ]
takes his hat off and i'm like this dude
cuts his own hair and not in a cute way
in a way like he's missing a lot of
parts here i'm like this this doesn't
look good and he fell asleep on the
train tracks yeah he doesn't look if
something's off and you're like this
dude's crazy it's like you don't want to
[ __ ] with the dude who's got nothing
yeah this dude has yes
so that's why i was kind of like let me
just try to get away from this [ __ ] i'm
not an idiot when someone [ __ ] with you
you get away you don't try to engage
with that [ __ ]
because they're [ __ ] with you because
they this is all they have yes you know
so
this other dude is a tough looking dude
who looks like
i'm not gonna say his race because it
could be any race but he's he's
screaming east new york [ __ ] and
he's like in his face and he's like he's
built he's like a tough looking guy
and i was like
first off this dude's my guardian angel
yeah second off like i would not [ __ ]
with this guy he's he's talking [ __ ]
about east new york what and i'm like
he's going to kill this guy he's asian
[Laughter]
anyway this filipino gentleman who's
saving me east new york [ __ ] in
his face and the guy is like ah he's
like backing down little yeah the ticket
guy is like guys please and he's like
[ __ ] off and the guy's like ah runs away
the train this ticket guy wants away
yeah he doesn't want his this dude who's
[ __ ] starting [ __ ] is like no one
wants to get in his way
you know he's
let him do what he wants the train stops
the cops come they both get arrested
and i'm like what did he ever were there
fisticuffs or anything i didn't see it
okay but
it was like right there if it happened
it happened yeah yeah but i did i missed
that part because i'm like i'm gonna i'm
gonna throw on some [ __ ] music yeah
the earphones you know
but uh i'm like let them do whatever the
[ __ ] they want i'm glad he [ __ ] with
another dude yeah i think that's what
like that's what like city type of [ __ ]
prepares you for is that you're like i
know when to walk away because i know
i'm not a fighter so when people talk
[ __ ] to me i'm like i'm gonna go over
here you're gonna keep talking [ __ ]
you'll run into the wrong guy and that's
natural selection exactly
because he's gonna [ __ ] your ass up and
we're gonna get rid of this [ __ ] talking
yes
i can't believe that guy ain't me yeah
sam i got i got confessed that ending
was underwhelming
i thought you were going somewhere else
with it yeah you think with a turtleneck
new york [ __ ] i think i was like what
what
here's what will wanted to hear
he wanted the guy with the shitty hair
to go put your mouth on the curb like ah
that's what you want to hear from me
what i don't throw me some crazy [ __ ] i
thought so too but thank you mark yeah
no the cops came and they both got
arrested that's all that happened all
right that's just another day
oh it's another day we're talking about
east new york that made me think of it i
apologize east new york is tough man
yeah yeah
yeah they used to
they used to um
steal your i remember my i i used to
have my mother
bought me
some expensive snakes one time oh and
she said they ever steal them never
again right so i used to carry my cheat
sneakers and my expensive snake wow so
when i got to the uh the my school and
the good neighborhoods i had my
expensive sneakers on then when i when
neighborhoods get a little you know
yeah [ __ ] swap sneakers and
those those sheep sneakers were my
guardian angels really they were my east
new york because
they'll look at your speed they're like
oh yeah you ain't talking about nothing
ah you know what i'm saying
what were they keeping what were they
expensive
you know the like the boat shoes
the sparring the white people were yeah
yeah no you don't see what i'm saying
you're wearing boat shoes in east new
york yeah not yet but they cheap boat
shoes like three dollars it was oh yeah
big basket river shoes huh i'm [ __ ]
yeah it was cheap shoes and but those
shoes are the ones that saved me oh wow
and i used to have two expensive ones oh
i had adidas
some adidas
that was back in the run dmc yeah adidas
adidas shelter yeah yeah i had the the
shitty bike and the good bike in my
neighborhood but every time i took the
good bike i would get stolen and then i
would see the guy riding around my bike
stolen from you or you left it got
stolen both i've had both
i got the bike stolen from under me
twice and then uh once how they take it
what'd they do one time it was a
christmas gift and they stole it like
christmas eve where
in my neighborhood
how did they take it from you though oh
they just you know one time two guys or
three guys excuse me they were a little
older than me ah so embarrassing i came
from summer camp and i had face paint it
was fake face paint day and we painted
[ __ ] on kids like really little kids i
was probably 13. and i had a a rainbow
on this side and a
like a like a candy bar or a cloud or
something cute on the other universe you
deserve to get your bike stolen i know i
know and these kids kept rubbing their
front tire on my back tire and i was
like oh i'm good i'm good but the face
paint i'm about to say they had they was
on on bikes also yeah yeah and then uh
it's like mad max it was it was yeah it
felt just like that and i'm like so
close to home i'm like three blocks away
but they kept rubbing their front tire
on my back tire and i was like i'm good
i'm good and then they
what were they telling you what were
they saying like let me try your bike
let me try your bike that's what they
kept saying and i was like i'm good no
thank you and they would pull up in
front of me and i had to stop and
you couldn't i'll erase them no i
couldn't these guys were on i was on
like a you know regular bike these guys
had souped up bikes right
and uh eventually
i had i was sitting on the bike and i
remember telling myself don't get off
the bike if you get off the bike it's
over and eventually one of the guys
pushed me and i fell off the bike but i
kept holding the handle right he did
like that and my hand fell off and he
went check yeah and rode away and i
started crying and ran home
fun times how old were you i was like
13. oh i didn't say last week yeah i was
28.
[Laughter]
mark still paints his face and it does
not play well here
i know
that was a nice bike too it was like a
like a mountain bike oh your mom's
bought it for you yeah
my bike got stolen christmas eve and i
remember christmas morning they rode
past us and my dad was like [ __ ]
this neighborhood you know he went nuts
you your dad didn't go out to the bike
well they were riding away wasn't going
to run after it he was in a row get in
the car and then and then his his car
will with their bike tire oh i wish he
didn't care that much but he was like i
spent you know 50 bucks on that thing
and that was the 90s what uh well do you
have any peeves any any pet peeves any
things that will really bother you
lately um
pet peeve sickle cell let's
see uh
what else the man
i i don't like when people keep saying
the same thing over and over again like
if we're talking they keep saying you
know well i really like that i really
like like ah i get it i get it oh yeah
i'm with you on that yeah because then
you have to keep reacting yeah like you
don't know how yeah looks like the
conversation has come to a stand still
they're not adding anything new then
anything new but they keep bringing up
every every few seconds
oh that's a nice jacket man all right
thanks oh that's the worst yeah cause if
you stop going all right i got it to go
cheers i'm just trying to gobble at you
and well like first off there's my cheap
jacket the good ones in the bag right
here
yeah
i'm with you on that the repeating yeah
yeah the pet peeve um i hate when
somebody tells a joke and it doesn't get
a laugh so they keep telling it like you
guys must have missed it like no no the
joke sucked you should have just kept it
going kept it quiet we had to keep
telling the joker i think i retold one
on this episode because will said what
and i hated myself i was angry i did it
because i know people were listening
like why do we tell that shitty jokes
but the what i'm sorry the what prompts
the retelling i know i'm talking about
the guy who's just bombing and he keeps
telling it like oh you guys must have
missed it like no no we caught it no we
never really tell a joke honestly
because if it didn't get a laugh the
first time there might be a reason for
that right right oh you know when when
comics they um
though
that where they they stick to script so
much
like they don't bear away from the
scripture they'll do a joke
and and let's say you know the crowd is
not laughing they'll still stick to
script they'll be like yeah and i took
my wife's pillow
you laugh now but my wife didn't think
it's funny
it's like the christ's not even laughing
yeah you laugh now but my wife didn't
think it's funny like dude like the
autopilot comedian yeah
we call them the push play comic right
right
where they're like they have the crowd
work that's preordained so they kind of
look at someone like this black guy
knows what i'm talking about it's like a
white guy right there
that's how scripted their act is or how
about the guy who's like so i [ __ ]
your wife the other day oh you guys
can't handle it like yeah we're on board
what do you mean you can't handle it the
name of a joke about you can't handle it
like no we're fine yeah we were always
laughing yeah the guy with the
pre-scripted rant oh you didn't like
that joke here's a two-minute rant why
you should have you're like no we all
liked the joke he laughed what are you
doing oh they're pointing someone in the
back or they yeah the push in the back
didn't like it like
right right i mean i'll go as far and
this is maybe i shouldn't say out loud
but the kamiku like the middle eastern
comet goes on i know you thought i was a
terrorist no wait you were booked you're
a comedian it's america like when no one
thought you were a terrorist oh you know
what no one's like this guy's good he's
a terrorist
you know what happened to me in the in
uh what year was that 98
i won't say the name of the comedy club
though
i went to economy clubs danger fields uh
and i asked can i get on and they said
oh we already have our black comic for
the week
for the week yeah
we already have our black comment for
the week but you can understand right
back then
i thought that was the norm
because it was white clubs white people
white communities so i'm thinking okay
maybe
they i i'm thinking i'm not thinking
racist something and or maybe the white
crowd don't want to see black comics and
like uh another black comic you know
saying something it should be at least a
month
february
yes so but i mean as crazy as it sounds
that sounds today yeah back then it's
like i'm like okay so i'm so i went to
another so i started looking up clubs
that didn't have a black comic right and
i'm like damn all these clubs got a
black comic for the
that they always [ __ ] with right they
got the token black you know you know
alt comedy where that came from i just
found out what you know all comments
alternative yeah but
it really stands for
doing a comedy show at a place that's
not a comedy club i know i remember
learning about this
but black black comedian started that ah
because you guys wouldn't let us in into
the club yeah guys you guys
yeah you can't say uh 20 years younger
than you [ __ ] what do you think
i'm doing two of the pete that one's a
club well i could say i stole my bike
[Laughter]
with black people wow i thought it was
implied
like i said you're my guardian angel
yeah but i will say dude i hear what
you're saying i mean look no hold on
i'll say the negro leagues were talking
lost
baseball league too no i was saying oh
interesting i was saying was they
wouldn't they would so we should start
club our shows at bars restaurants
whatever but then somehow old comedy got
turned into
not like you guys took that from us
you guys
pointed to us yeah
took it from us and made it something
else because now when you hear alt com
you don't think of like a comic club a
comic should not accomplish think of
weird or different kind of yeah like
nerd comedy don't talk about when did
that start totally totally all comedy is
funny i mean when mark and i were coming
up you know we we came up after you will
but like when we were coming up all
comics were the ones getting all the tv
shows yeah mark and i were always
resentful because i think we
were always kind of road guys and club
guys and we thought we were working
really hard on honing our stuff and we'd
see these old guys who got up not nearly
as much as us and who we didn't think
had chops and we're getting all the tv
spots so we were always a little bit
like
who the [ __ ] are these guys meanwhile
they were doing a totally different
thing a lot of them are hilarious you
know there's a lot of great old comics
but you know
a lot of that stuff dried up because
they were not doing the repetition
where they were doing like their
brooklyn show or something but they
weren't going up in the midwest
and you know there's a reason that [ __ ]
played to a very small demographic i
think sometimes yeah ironically it was
the least inclusive kind of comedy like
they couldn't go outside of their bubble
right it was it was like kind of very
liberal yes then it was kind of like all
on inside joke exactly a lot of it was
i'd find a lot of those i'd do those
rooms always you know we had gaffigan on
last week we talked about like the
necessity to do all the rooms sure you
can talk about all this [ __ ] but like
and and connect to any audience because
there's an importance in being able to
have that i think we all pride ourselves
on that but
you do some of these rooms and it would
be like some anti-comedy [ __ ] some guy
going up mocking like a road hack and
i'd watch some of these guys like well
you don't have the tools to even be a
road hack yeah yeah
you're mocking this [ __ ] but like to to
break the rules you kind of have to know
the rules a little bit and you see some
of these great like film directors and
they're kind of mocking cinema but a lot
of times it'd be like robert altman and
you'd be like well he's a genius
director you know so it means someone
like that and so
well what the thing is with all kind
like
okay so that was the beginning of all
comedy you know black but somehow it
switched to the type of jokes you're
telling right yes and then the type of
clubs you're working where it's not kind
of clubs but so what was all what is
what did all time turned into like what
type of jokes were people saying it
turned into
janine garofalo looking at her notes and
it turned into cool coffee yeah but
colin quinn does a show at the comedy
cell every monday look at his notes
but she she popularized it
and i i like jane i like janine too i
think what mark's saying is like
sometimes when someone break through
doing a certain thing others pop others
follow for the wrong reasons right you
know like maybe people saw janine do the
notes thing and they took that as a hint
that they could use it as an excuse to
not be funny like they look at their
notes but they'd be doing their a
material right and they'd be like anyway
what else and then they'd do their a
[ __ ] and it's like all right well
you know you're either working on it or
not like we all you know look up to
colin quinn because colin is always
trying to grow as a comic and colin is
always like you know this sounds
pretentious as [ __ ] but colin is like
seeking [ __ ] like colin is looking to
grow as a comic always and that's why
i've always looked up to colin but the
alt comic is one thing but the old
audience do they purposely go hey let's
go and not laugh like
it sure as hell feels like it sometimes
i don't know we bomb there all day long
i go there but i do feel like though
some of those brooklyn crowds like i'll
always do it because i think it's
important to always you know kind of
do different rooms that are not do the
crowd know that they're all crowded they
call themselves old crowd no they're not
as energized i do think there's like
more of a standards and practices in
their brain being like is this okay to
laugh at oh for sure exactly not
original old crowd black shows they
laughed they laughed like you watched f
comedy jam talk about energized oh shoot
i used to do do you ever do smokey's
room and mocha lounge yeah yeah that was
a [ __ ] alt room yeah holy [ __ ] my
show i i bought some comic club every
sundays i heard about this yeah bro bill
bro you break it up he used to kill kill
yeah because
because well i had trained the room to
laugh
but don't boo don't heckle
because black black shows the good comes
with the bad like yes kill but if you're
not killing you also will
kill yourself it's like a roman coliseum
time it's either great or you're killing
well as the boston comic-con i'm like no
we're not doing that we're not oh really
doing none of that if you don't like
someone just beat that that's nice and
then and so
uh robert kelly rich foss jim norton
they used to come there and just kill
that's the irony is like
like i've done i've started the alt
world and it was all about like hey we
got to be nice and da da and then you go
to these
brooklyn or bronx room minorities it's
all black rooms or whatever and it's
vicious and fun and dirty and filthy and
you're like all the [ __ ] you guys say
that minorities are all about they're
doing the other [ __ ] you know like it's
it's kind of condescending in a weird
way well it's michael jay's great joke
about how liberals love to be offended
on behalf of right i always think of
michael chase joke about that it's like
there is
something incredibly pretentious about
that yeah he likes you guys can't feel
how offensive this
for you it's very well you can't say you
guys you got to say you them you them
oh marina franklin's great joke about i
love mourinho's joke about how pronouns
are like you're gonna make me say they
about someone you're gonna make me talk
like a runaway slave
they went that way i mean like that's a
[ __ ] brilliant joke brilliant
you just hacked it and you just made it
you just messed it up yeah i messed it
up now you can't use it she can't use it
on the road
i'm joking [ __ ] sorry i think that
joke's out there know what she did on
conan all right she's funny as hell i
love marina i love marina i will say
this you know
which by the way i hate when people say
that that's a peeve and i just did it
myself i just built up what i will say
this [ __ ] me
what am i going to say another thing
when people say at the end of the day
yeah yeah yeah
at midday i'm going to say that right
right right exactly you know what top of
the morning i think it should be sad oh
let me find some more peeps yeah how
about this one
the guy who won't stop harping on the
fact that he's making a point you know
he's like i'll tell you i think whiskey
is better than vodka you go i like
whiskey too he's like i'm just saying
whiskey's better than vodka i'm a fan
i'm not a huge fan of vodka i like
whiskey i'm with you but look can a guy
have an opinion i agree with you
[ __ ] give it up it's over it
kind of it's kind of going back to this
guy who says the same [ __ ] over and over
yeah
yeah it's i think we just get bored
easily we're all we all live in our
heads right so when someone's speaking
just to speak we're just like just we
could be science oh i know another pet
peeve i hate yeah
um when a hot girl walk this and this is
like not even just back then i used to
hate it when a hot girl walked by and
another dude was looking at me like hey
huh huh uh-huh like dude i'm not come on
what's wrong i purposely not look at
like when a hot girl walk by and these
dudes around i purposely not look at
guys faces because i don't want them to
go yeah that's the [ __ ] she's doing like
so you look at the woman yeah like you
think that's a better move you think the
guy's like oh cool he's just checking
out the woman i'm with
no i'm saying like you don't talk about
when a girl walked by and and and
another guy would look and two guys look
at each other like two stranger dudes
like huh huh huh i hate that what's the
other option you look at her i feel like
no but i'm saying i don't like don't
like
enjoy her on your own ah don't freaking
break me into this don't bring him into
like well done yeah like yeah yeah i
know i hear that you know what is it a
gay thing
no i think it's just kind of like you're
trying to bond over a chick and that's
weird it's just like
i think that's a great unifier i mean
every race every guy from any place in
the world a beautiful woman walks in we
all go hey she's hot huh no but he's
talking about if it's like you're with
that woman oh
yeah that's weird yeah that's weird i
get you on that i mean women are women
already have it hard
and like like i always i tell guys like
you know what it is to be like to be a
woman like walking around
go go to prison
i feel like they're not going to take
you up on that dare yeah
and you feel like what it is to be a
woman walking about yeah interesting
constantly that's a good bit
that's funny
anyone know what it's like to be a woman
[ __ ] walk mark walk through [ __ ]
rikers with those lips buddy that's
where you'll [ __ ] you'll feel what
it's like uh well these women luckily
don't have to shower publicly
but yeah i like that that's a good point
what about the women who or the guys who
claim to be a woman when they go to
prison that's a smart move
that's i mean that's then they go to the
women's prison they go i identify as a
woman do you want to make that do that
do that is that where they go to to yeah
if you identify as a woman i think it
was in australia there's a good story
about this uh these guys identified as
women and they went to women's prison
yeah yeah which sounds like a comedy
book that's not that sounds like yeah
sound like bulls and buddies now true
story i i gotta watch somebody's nothing
i love muslim buddies i got p if when
people will post [ __ ] like this like
name something better
i'll wait
well you're gonna be waiting a long time
because i'm not gonna be conversing with
you [ __ ]
on social media yeah name something
better
i'll wait uh
yeah the reason no one has a response is
because we just hate you so much so
we're not gonna play your [ __ ] game
well that's a hard thing like you know
will is obviously we're all doing the
road so we have to be somewhat covert
cautious because you know we don't want
to cancel a weekend sure like we get
cold weekend a week two weeks a week
right yeah you could i mean look with
you gotta get a negative test so
uh we're all boosted so i don't think
the simpsons are gonna be horrible at
our age but like you have to look at
that [ __ ] is like that's a lot of money
to leave on the table yeah but like
certain to people now you talk to you
have a conversation with someone you you
just have a stop and chat it would annoy
you because you didn't want to talk to
that person now you're like this is the
person that's gonna [ __ ] infect me
yeah this conversation i don't want to
have so true it's going to give me
coffee
that's right that's right yeah i like
talking with it i'm we're talking with
aziz i think i told you guys
like it's he keeps a bubble tight
you know and yeah and
and it's fun because it's a fun bunch
so not like you gotta go out and and
find fun [ __ ] today right right like we
all me phil ricky velaz beth you guys
know beth right
yeah oh i love best one of the best
[ __ ] amazing great good egg yeah
she's booking fellaini [ __ ] now yeah she
worked yeah and and she and just that
it's just fun like he's like oh [ __ ] i
you know i'm saying we don't need
anything else
i i also i hate the uh a pet peeve
currently for me is people with their
masks just on their mouth but now the
nose is out are they talking to you
you're like well just go no mask at that
point it's silly
it's like
your underwear right here you know yeah
it feels silly to yeah go commando yeah
why wouldn't that do that that you they
wore a thong on his face
on the plane he actually got hired by
victoria's secret
but i saw that that was funny that's
like like that guy's an [ __ ] for so
many reasons yeah
yeah man it's all good peeves i i can't
give you guys a wreck give me a wreck
what's a wreck recommendation oh i
thought like a wreck like erect but
just a wreck
so wreck and the iraq here's my wreck
man
it's simple it's easy
it's it's
you guys a lot of guys it's january
you're trying to be healthy right who's
not trying to be i mean as i said i'm
guzzling scotch yeah you say this is
your we're all trying to be a little
more healthy in january that's just how
it is sure
healthy snack that's delicious i don't
know if we've done this before we drink
every episode uh mark but uh take some
grapes
throw them in the freezer mm-hmm it's a
[ __ ] treat oh my lady does this every
night they're great treats she loves it
yeah they're delicious it's a good it's
a little cold for me oh i throw them
right next to the fetus in my freezer
and frozen grapes yeah with your
medication
you don't like them i mean you're vegan
you could get by on that just fold
i don't maybe i don't like the can i
give it a break can i get a give away
sure it better be better than this we'd
be honored i'll wait
if you're talking to someone and you're
not sure they got covered or not right
yeah
all you got to do is while they yap with
that but doing
don't inhale ah
so like if you're yapping right go ahead
that hey will you look great and i think
it's cool that you're vegan and also
i see what you're doing you're not
inhaling exactly yeah like bill clinton
don't inhale but what do you do when he
talks forever you got to go
you know how does that work well then
you get up and go i'll go back go back
does that keep you from getting covered
not in here well because you inhale not
you know say you
the the you're thinking for your your
nose like a vacuum yep it's sucking in
the coconut wait maybe you can still get
it without inhaling not necessarily
really cause it just hopefully matt is
this is this true i assume
how can you get it if you if you're not
sucking it in your nose how come it goes
in that's why we were a mask yeah but
because you inhale i know that's what
i'm saying i'm saying is someone's
yapping i'm not saying you're wrong i'm
just saying i don't know if this is true
i'm saying someone yeah but that was
doing about nothing you just
it has made talking to people you don't
want to talk to
a little more intense
i'm not even worried really about
getting sick i'm more worried about
canceling dates at this point yeah right
because omnicron omicron is not really
those omicron omicron sorry it's not
hard not those symptoms seem to be mild
if you especially guys like us who are
all boosted if you get vaccinated the
symptoms seem to be boosted it's more
just about like if you test positive
you're not supposed to travel and work
so you have to isolate i mean first up
if i think if you're vaccinated they
should reduce that [ __ ] i think they
have reduced it to five days they have
so that's something what do you got here
so brad uh three strangers on the street
and when you shoot don't inhale well
you're [ __ ] good i mean how else
would it get in huh how else would it
get in it makes sense yeah see
there you go so only do anal
or doggy style because then you can
still [ __ ] and not inhale i'll try to
aim at one time if you're not breathing
in you dramatically cut down on the risk
logically i mean
hey this is all about risk right risk
reward folks wait can i tell y'all
something please i thought taking anal
and giving in there was i thought giving
in though like you give your ass
i'm taking it or you're taking ass did
you go to prison
[Laughter]
no but doesn't that sound like it does
yeah
like
someone if you didn't know english
language you're interesting will because
you're like in prison i don't know who
you'd be that's the thing because you
are you are a boxer you're tough hold on
but you're also not a huge guy i mean
you're a lightweight boxer easy hammer
what is this hammer thing where'd that
come from if you didn't know english and
someone said yo you want to get better
no you want to take anal what would you
say
i would say you need to learn english
no
are you on medication i'm saying if you
didn't know that yes i am if you didn't
know english it's alcohol
and someone said you want get ready no
take it what would you say
i would rather give it you give you give
your anal no rather give my penis no i'm
saying he's getting point he's got a
point thank you because you're like
giving up your ass this is good this is
like
this is like carlin in prison
how did given anal
turn
the other way he got something here i
think someone did it came up with it to
trick you hey you want to give another
yeah i'll give anal yeah because the
girl says i'll give him some [ __ ] yeah
yeah i'll give him some anal yeah so am
i
how how am i wrong
all right all right my girlfriend says
i'm going to give him some [ __ ] she
actually puts a strap on on
you guys do what you have to do
you do what you have to do you pranked
before uh i haven't have you no i never
would you no i wouldn't get i don't even
like a
tongue in my [ __ ] really what you
told me you did that was the worst night
of my life that we [ __ ] bonded buddy
would you ever mark take a tongue no
hell yeah i've taken it a peg
no
i don't think so why why why did she put
a strap on with a little tongue
oh
now you're talking is it wet
it's a wet tongue but is it considered
pecking no and it's it's a gene simmons
strap-on
that's a big that's a
[Music]
tail tail damn it but you guys eat
tongue yeah cow tongue cow yeah that's a
jewish deli thing too and and mexicans
do they do
cow tongue oh yeah get out of here it's
a deli meat thing so i always knew
blacks and jews were similar we're very
similar bro there you go john stewart
used to have the great bit is how uh you
know jews we complain black people
the blues like he had the idea you guys
put it to music that was the john
stewart baseball cast you wear yarmulkes
there you go right yeah
but you know what were we talking about
before this you had the apartments
who's benefiting from pagan
the guy you're the guy it's you it's
your prostate is the male g-spot not now
just a hint now but can two dudes peg
i don't know i don't need the strap on
well i'm not attracted to men so i think
like the argument is now like
you know
is taken in the ass gay and the answer
is no
taking or giving
i knew it was going there i walked into
that one no i don't see jeff after this
i should say i limped but
i you know
no i do think you know the whole thing
is like there is a homophobia around it
but you know the male g-spot is in the
butthole like who said who everybody
keeps saying this who who said this who
said it i don't know matt am i wrong can
we get some data back me up please
i've heard that you milked the prostate
you milk it yeah have you if you you've
never had it properly then i feel sorry
for you
i used to have a bit about that you get
the milk going i love the milk
[Music]
what is that there it is and the rest of
the hand i go just a hint what's the get
the milk go i don't know what that mean
milk the prostate in your butthole
you you're in wild turkey
i'm on lagerville and right really yeah
[ __ ] where does get the milk
going now let me ask you this you have a
lady and you go hey can you milk milk me
and she goes i don't do that [ __ ] no oh
wow i don't think i mean i don't know
maybe i don't remember that [ __ ] but
like yeah i mean also if a woman's not
into something you just say cool i mean
it's like people are not into [ __ ] i
don't remember who's into what but right
right i will say this
maybe some chicks like it
it is
i mean i think i'm into getting a woman
off so wouldn't she be in it getting me
off yeah i'm more into getting a woman
out than getting me off right yeah
you're a giver i'm i freaking get turned
on by when the woman get turned on same
like i'm like
as do i but i think i'd like i'd like to
favor return like many times i go to
sleep uh un
uncummed all right
damn i think i think you just say
regular
that's not time uncomfortable maybe a
pegging is an order
what well i'm just saying if you can't
get off i think you probably have to
work your way up to that i think if
you've never had a finger in the ass and
you just get paid you'd be like this is
[ __ ] horrible no i you missed the
point meaning i enjoy like she comes
once twice three times and my night is
done i'm i'm i'm good well you're too
much i mean you made you're like a bus
boy in the bedroom you may as well just
[ __ ] call your night i mean here's my
thing you deserve some some loving too
just call me boy
[Laughter]
we're gonna call this episode matt jesus
christ i've walked into a few this this
episode i've made a sickle cell joke
i've made all these jokes and he's just
going after you no he trolls me because
will here's the thing will has trolled
me for years and that's part of our
friendship i mean maybe because you look
like he drove amistad
i wore the wrong shirt for this episode
it's heat tech it keeps you warm it's
freezing it's 25 degrees outside heat
deck i think i went to that school
i went to university to heat online
[Laughter]
you got a bit you're working on a bit um
a joke
a half-baked idea
hold on let me take a look real quick
all right all right
i got too many bits so i'd rather work
on you guys i've got a few turds right
here i'd rather you guys come
than me get off
all right well what do you got you go
first all right sam we got one go first
mine all right i got a big idea
now this this might have been done so
tell me if you've heard this please i
feel the same about mine okay
you know you listen to hip hop and a lot
of rappers
like claim to be gangsters and it's very
mob influenced you know it's like
scarface gang star mob deep 36 mafia
it's very mob heavy but yet all they do
is go on a microphone and snitch they go
this is who i'm [ __ ] that's what i'm
killing this is how much money i make
where a real mobster would never do that
if a real mobster was a rapper he'd be
like i'm in sanitation i'm a family man
you're like i died on 23rd street i
don't know anything about that you know
it'd be the opposite of of rap so that
that that's where i'm interesting yeah
the name of something called i don't
know what you're talking about
that's good check out my new album waste
management yes
yeah there's something funny about that
about like really
being a gangster the less you say
is gangster right right i remember
listening to vincent curtala on on de
paulo's podcast and you know he played
johnny sack on the sopranos oh yeah
everyone was yelling in the audition
room
for that role johnny said he goes i'm
gonna whisper because that's what being
a gangster is interesting being a
gangster is real power so you don't have
to yell right so that's kind of what
you're saying right interesting totally
still water runs deep
there you go yeah
so you think there's something here with
this bit
yeah i think it's funny like vegas power
vegas power yeah who am i who am i
[ __ ] come up with doesn't matter
i've got options that's the point i
think you can actually come up with two
bars real quick yeah i think you're
right i'll be funny i actually wrote
some [ __ ] down yeah let's hear it oh
[ __ ] this is scary i mean go all the way
out all right all right
rapper colin i make stack after stack
from selling crack i'm the richest man
in the nation mobster says i make a
comfortable living i'm in sanitation
so i got 20 more bars i do okay
i do okay it's funny i do okay because
they're all like my kids i'm a family
man they got their gumar whereas a
rapper's like i [ __ ] every chick in
america you know well that's the other
thing is like real gangster [ __ ] is like
real rich people act like they're poor
aha cause like gangsters are always like
you know if you if you hear like rap
they're like a lot of it's bravado so
it's like you're selling records by
being like this is how much i have but
look at that like rich people are rich
people don't tip
interesting like they're going to drive
a prius they don't tip at all i heard
puffy doesn't tip at all really yeah
yeah but i mean how much money are you
saving exactly i've actually heard him
say my money my problems
oh you know the chorus line could be you
ask me what it's about i tell you i
don't know what you're talking about
nothing oh
i thought that was a real song you had
me there
i don't know what you're talking about
yeah that's funny all right all right
that was mine and i read a rap so you
guys are i i got um
uh i found out that
people take anti-depression pills um
they pee most of it out your body just
use very but it mostly goes in your
pizza you pee
most of it just goes in the in the ocean
which is perfect because
you ever see fish they look all
depressed
[Laughter]
right fish are just
yeah they need more depression
anti-depression pills
that's why they always
grab the hook i'm gonna kill myself oh
the suicide yeah that's great oh i like
it how do you know these fishes are like
just like i'm okay you know what yo you
know you're not supposed to bite the
hook [ __ ] that i'm out of here
at least their goodbye world comes with
a treat oh yeah the worm the bait
we jump off a roof they get a [ __ ]
cookie on the way out yeah you jump on
your worm they eat the worm oh maybe
when you know some people catch and
release they throw them back the fish is
like what the [ __ ] i got out i was
trying to kill myself it's like when you
take pills and they pump your stomach
yeah yeah it's like that's funny dude
that's something that's funny
all right i'm trying to think of some uh
some fish names salmon trout flounder
catfish what is that a funny name so it
sounds sad
hmm
throwing i think throwing back is funny
i mean you
you you're like finally i'm out of this
[ __ ] cesspool and then they throw you
back and like well now i'm back with a
scar i guess all right all the fishes i
thought you was out of here yeah a lot
of people too when they kill themselves
they go walk into the ocean so they're
like i gotta be amongst my sad people i
gotta be around the fish the fish is
depressed imagine they get thrown back
got rejected like
he's more depressed like
even people don't want me right right
oh that's that's funny patrice said that
great bit about like no one cares if you
kill fish because they have no eyebrows
you know so there's like
so they don't look sad but you kill a
you know a cow and he's like
[Music]
that's his bit
not mine
uh i like that that's good
sam what you got i got a few ideas let
me try this on you like this one was
like just make sure this hasn't been
done i was talking to a guy and he was
saying something like kind of anti-trans
[ __ ] to me and i was kind of like you're
scottish your whole history is dudes
i like that have you heard that just
dudes and kilts like he's like you guys
disgust me and he goes oh this it's my
grandfather's right here right is that
something there yeah there's something
there for sure something about
anti-trans but it's like you're the
manliest man the scots
you wear dresses
let's calm down yeah i it's like i grew
up with this guy he was super racist
hated black people wait what's super
racist versus regular races i'm talking
i'm regular
i mean he was like n-word this and we're
at that they shouldn't be allowed here
you know like all all in
but he loved sports yeah and i'm like
that's all black people it's all nba nfl
it's all black well technically
yeah what are you in the cricket
yeah right technically because they look
at us as sting dance for us so they
don't look at sports as like if they
look at us like yeah good just like the
romans right who they used to send in
the pit to fight their lives yeah or the
people they sending their cousins their
uncles right that's it i never thought
about that all right you got something
there but like how can you be a racist
and then tap your foot to michael
jackson shouldn't you be like i hate
this [ __ ] guy again back to the uh
entertainer entertainer no entertain us
but i think it's funny that historically
like you have the most effeminate man
costume yes and you're like we don't
accept men who dress like women well you
do that
yeah it's dead on i mean you you guys
you dress like women right
i like it i like it i'm trying to think
where to go with it the the stop scots
are actually the worst trans people
because they don't they got the hairy
legs they got the beard they don't go
all the way
well i'm just saying they're like
at least trans people go all in they get
the surgery they go they wouldn't take
the pills
scottish people were like you made me
look at your legs at least [ __ ]
wax them yes
right they don't wear underwear under
those either by the way oh yeah yeah the
kilts you took a peek oh yeah
you better believe it
i got another one hit me
um
you're watching news they they like
they're like uh crime crime is up
compared to 2020. i'm like
no one was out in 2020
that's like they always comparing crime
or whatever to 2020 yeah like all of
2021 that was doing that right you know
like
you know you know uh traffic is is up
compared to 2020 like
yeah everyone's inside yeah with crime i
think a lot of the time they don't get
the data till like much later because
like cases are kind of tried and stuff
like that but it's also hilarious that
we've been in a pandemic
and you're like this we compare it to
this other time and you're like all
right but
we haven't lived in a long time yeah
yeah everything's up the only thing
that's not up is
i guess
staying indoors yeah another thing is
like
when we was not uh
you know driving around how can they fix
the votes when nobody was in the roads
good point
i guess they didn't want to be around
other people fixing [ __ ] no they were
doing they were still i'm not sure you
guys went out during 2020 they were
still there but they they didn't
you know
they had that was a perfect time to fix
the votes uh yeah totally fix everything
yeah all that construction [ __ ] yeah why
wasn't the de blasio de blasio you don't
like him no i like it he's gone we
no no one did that cuomo
he was a homosexual i was i didn't like
his politics but i like what he did uh
off the field
[Laughter]
no i uh no i'm a big uh
i'm a big uh anti de blasio guy i cuomo
is obviously a a horror show he's a
liberal when you compliment a girl you
you go hey i like your hair no cuomo
too soon no i mean let's see what adams
does i'm excited i'm even if he's bad
i'm excited to get a new bed
right hey guys i think what did de
blasio do that was bad bad like what was
the top three bad things he did that's
what i don't know much about i think
food
that's not probably there's like
you're living in i think i think a lot
of being a politician is for me a lot of
being a politician is being a leader and
and uniting people and i think he was as
bad as it gets he's definitely divided i
mean when you stand for nothing
you have nothing so
i think he alienated cops i think he
alienated liberals i think alienated
conservatives so it's like no one when
no one likes you no one comes together
about you like say what you want about
bloomberg who i wasn't like a huge
bloomberg guy either but like he at
least made an effort to to connect to
people i think i think
bloomberg i mean i think uh de blasio
lacked a connection to
the working class to the elite to
everyone in new york and when you do
that
you kind of bring together no one and
i think it really was like the nail in
the coffin when he was just like dancing
on new year's eve with his wife and i'm
like this has been a horrible year you
can't be out celebrating dude right you
mean how like um um uh what's that guys
chris christie was on the beach when
they shut the beach down and him and his
family was on the beach oh yeah and he
was scaring away all the kids they
thought it was a whale but
no i mean
so de blasio i think
literally everyone is saying good
riddance i think he's been horrible i
think he's been out for power rather
than uh you know it's similar to
giuliani where new yorkers like giuliani
a lot after 9 11 because of what he did
but then it was all about a power grab
and running for president and speaking
engagements and money and you're like
well you don't i know we all know you
don't care about us but you got to at
least fake it a little better than de
blasio did kind of how i feel well said
what do you what do you think
i i i mean de blasio i mean they
most most most of these politicians is
like
especially in the u.s you never had any
good
good ones i'm sure these good ones don't
get me wrong but it's you know i think
there's so many people that everybody
had their own opinions so when we're so
divided yeah yeah you know so there'll
never be anybody i mean look look we
know you guys remember we know yeah i
sent him a photo yeah he sent me one it
was terrible
i mean it's amazing how like
when he was running right
and then he got caught with his dick out
mm-hmm and by the way he denied it i
know and he was on some show and they oh
what i think was what's his name girl
like larry king he's like is that your
penises no that's not what penis by the
way he had a great body for yeah like
politician that's a stressful job to be
as fit as he was or like ripped good job
and a good dick by the way was it i
don't know i'll do it but i remember the
i remember the physique being like not
bad pull up the dick but check this out
he he uh denied it then
made it last first by the way when you
got caught just
admitted right so it could just end
quickly yeah and then they finally it
was his dick
and then he he was trash for his poor
wife
he dragged her through
a dong there
foreign we're gonna have to believe a
lot of this man i mean i'm we've given
matt so much worth this week i'm sorry
man you're gonna believe energized
yeah yeah he's like
he looks better than what was who who's
the other guy that bezos the bezos yeah
i know but that's one of those bodies
where you're like you don't expect it
either because he looks like kind of a
scrawny dweeb right that neck and then
you're like [ __ ] he's ripped oh yeah but
then look uh a year later he he he
apologized blah blah blah and then he
got more support second time around well
love it we love to forgive people he
said another dick pick out with his baby
in the back for perspective here's
here's here he was there was a
documentary on window that's great
actually really you know it's terrific
it's worthwhile called gay porn yeah it
is it was great but
no there's a doctor
and it's really really good and i do
think there is something about americans
we love
to drag people down a comeback we also
love a comeback story right well come on
back
but
you know the [ __ ] the thing is he [ __ ]
up for a second time way too soon you
can't do it that soon when people bring
you back new yorkers are forgiving
people yeah
we'll [ __ ] you up you [ __ ] don't
forget you're doing the same thing no no
i know
i think a lot of people are like dude we
just let you back in right like that is
and i'll say this too like
weiner if you watch those debates he
[ __ ] buried de blasio really oh you
know
he was on his way he was a great really
he was a great i mean dude he's like
from the clinton school of charm where
he knew
you you don't rise like this if you
don't know what you're doing he was like
new york mayor is a big gig yeah yeah
politically because new york's a big
state i mean of course like everyone
knows who gavin newsom is because
california is a big state like if you're
in a big state people know who the [ __ ]
you are you're heavy so it's it is a
stepping point to a big speaking gigs
book deal big money yeah or
governor senator whatever the [ __ ] you
want to do
so when he [ __ ] this up i think it was
kind of like oh you've got a sickness
dude oh maybe he was trying to give us a
hint if i become mayor i'm gonna [ __ ]
this town
nothing too soon sorry man
will give us gigs to plug man where are
you going
with the z's i'm not sure when this show
is aaron next week i'm turning with aziz
we're going we're going to uh
chicago's uh oakland san francisco
dc
uh new york city nice now well let me
ask you enough
about the comedy cellar by the way
always at the comedy celebration
on wednesdays with cypher sounds you
start a new joke night at the cellar
which is what comics we all get up when
we get to the joke tonight on the new
joke night every monday is 8 30 at
comrisella it was a because comics i
felt like when i created i felt like the
seller like you're always doing your
scripted [ __ ] because you want to kill
you know you go you you following some
amazing comedians so everybody's just
killing so i just wanted to create a
space where we could just
you know be a comedian not yeah you know
like just work out yeah put the script
down and just try some jokes and but
with a crowd yes like what we just did
just now a few miss a few minutes ago
with the jokes but with a crowd there
letting us letting us know and i'll come
in yeah but that would do with y'all
and and
and try to get some more of these jokes
hell yeah
all right and you got chemistry set and
i got chemistry said with cypher sounds
on my on wednesdays that's 10 30. it's a
dope dope show dope show i've i've had
some some good sets there and some bad
sets i don't remember the best so you'll
you'll be killing well i always
appreciate when you put me on a new
jokes man because it really helps it's
you know it's
it's great to have shows at the comedy
cellar that encourage new material
because yes
sometimes
even guys who've been there for a long
time we feel pressure you got to bring
it to yeah to bring new materia or to
bring the heat rather yeah you don't
like to yeah but that would do with me a
lot i don't yeah i do that goes in i
love it i do i've gotten i think i've
gotten better about it you always been
better what you mean oh you oh you've
never been bad what do you mean oh i
just yeah i get a little uh yeah i'll be
better about it i apologize i'll i'll be
like i gotta go like oh [ __ ] ah
come on
just to clear the air when i be having
that but doing with y'all it's not about
attacking y'all not but i take the joke
that way and i and i'm like yeah let's
let's try to create some more stuff yes
i love it like no no i'm sorry but i
feel like a lot of the time i do stay
and talk with you sometimes i've been i
gotta experience it because the black
thing you don't want to be around blacks
i'm racist
no it's it's that sometimes i have
another spot or something i know if i
can stay i want to stay
you tell me something about gorillas i
don't know you don't want to stay at the
zoo that's what he calls your shows
the jungle yeah
all right well yeah we love you but
wednesdays and mondays and every night
bob now here's the awkward question how
about an album how about a special we'll
put the [ __ ] on youtube we'll we'll
produce it oh yeah all right let's make
it happen all right where'd you really
put something out yeah
all right sounds good
you got 18 hours of material
i got yeah i got a lot of i mean 11 of
it it's good but
you got time
all right what are you going to do where
are you going to be
i got everything when does this come out
not this sunny but the next so yeah
richmond virginia timonium maryland it's
a baltimore area hartford connecticut
sacramento columbus
west palm orlando the beacon theater in
new york city baby hell yeah toronto
more dates coming we got more we're
announcing i can't announce some of it
yet but i i can't wait just speaking of
virginia you heard about the
traffic
shut down because of the snowstorm
like they were there's cars have been on
the road for 24 hours what
just sit in their car in traffic i it's
i don't even know it snowed there yeah
that global warming or what's going on
there no i'm not sure it was richmond
but he's in virginia dc
syracuse new york kansas city omaha
nebraska columbus ohio twice i got to
get a new uh
website lady la jolla california tampa
florida
syracuse i said that all over the road
des moines this weekend so yeah come on
who opened up for you i use a couple
guys he and laura every now and then uh
[Music]
chris allen chris allen he's he'll be
there in columbus who who you open who
you open up for you
where when you're on medication not
paying attention on the road it's
usually gary veeder sometimes deena
hashem i mean uh
dinner she's funny very very funny
whatever happened to her
all right we gotta wrap this thing up
you guys are great thanks a lot
thank you wilson vince we love you bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you